(dramatic music)
- I mean, I'm sure everybody
here is gonna cook with love
but you know,
her love is one that I'm used
to for the last 13 years.
So I think I'll be able to get it.
She likes her food very salty
but she's aware
that her preferences are not
like the mainstream preferences.
I've tried food from her portion before.
Like the amount of salt
that she enjoys is definitely
not the amount of salt
that I don't think anybody would enjoy.
(laughing)
- It's absurd.
- Did you wanna add some stakes to this?
- If I guess correctly,
then my reward is
that you have to clean
out the bedroom closet
all by yourself.
- Wow.
- But if I guess incorrectly,
then I have to do it all by myself.
- It's a bet.
- Let's make it happen.
(dramatic music)
- [Tenn] The three ingredients
I chose today are cheese,
olive oil and garlic.
I chose them to level the playing field
because obviously Swasti
knows me really well
but the other two chefs may not.
If I don't guess Swasti correctly
I'm just gonna be disappointed in myself.
(upbeat music)
- So I am making a creamy
garlic chicken pasta.
I love pasta.
So I feel like if I make something
that he knows I love to make,
he's gonna guess it.
So let's get started with the pasta,
gonna throw some pan up in here.
We have garlic powder,
paprika, Italian seasoning.
You can smell all the smells.
It's crazy you guys.
It's gonna be good.
Light note I have gloves
and I have washed my hands.
We've gotta put on some salt and pepper.
I love salt.
However I know not everyone else
likes the crazy amount
of salt that I like.
So we're gonna keep it simple.
Okay, now we got some pepper.
So I'm gonna get ready to cook
this chicken with olive oil.
And now it's time
to place it in the pot, all right.
Our chickens are cooked up on this side.
So I'm gonna give them a little flip.
Look at that.
Okay, to finish this chicken off,
we're actually going to
transfer it to the oven.
So it's time to move on to our sauce.
We're gonna start with some butter.
This pan is nice and flavorful.
Okay, this is basically melted.
So I'm going to place in the garlic
and I'm gonna let that kind
of soften up a bit in here.
I don't know if it's like necessary
but I just feel like it tastes better.
I mean, it smells good
cause you get to smell it
by itself for a second.
I'm gonna add in some
tomatoes, some spinach.
And now I'm going to kind
of mix it all together
and let this cook down a bit.
It is time to grab our chicken.
I'm gonna slice 'em up.
Look at that.
You can see how juicy they are.
They're like leaking on this board.
That's when you know
you've made a good chicken.
So I'm grabbing my pasta.
It's been sitting here for a second.
It's a little stuck up in here.
Now I'm gonna coat the
pasta with the sauce so
that it all kind of comes apart.
I don't understand how
people plate pasta so
that it looks nice,
but I figure it's okay.
You know, maybe that's my signature thing.
Blob in center Tenn will know it's me.
Now I'm gonna wrinkles sum
of ingredient number three,
that Parmesan cheese.
And Presto, that's it.
That's creamy garlic chicken pasta.
(upbeat music)
- Today. I'm making Spanakopita.
They are these spinach hand pies.
And I chose this recipe
because it incorporates
the three ingredients,
one being one of my
favorite cheese is feta,
little bit of ricotta cheese.
It highlights the garlic flavor for sure.
And we'll be using a
hefty amount of olive oil.
So we're gonna get started
by using our olive oil.
And we'll add in garlic.
And then we're gonna add in some scallions
and we're really just gonna make sure
that these are like nice
and coated in the oil.
We don't really wanna fry them.
We just wanna get them nice and soft.
Before we start adding all of our spinach.
Now we're gonna add our spinach
just a little bit at a time so
that we can wilt down
and it'll fit.
And then I'm gonna season the spinach
with a little bit of salt and pepper,
just to make sure we have
seasoning throughout.
Last time I did this,
I didn't add enough salt
and I got called out for it.
And so we're not going to make
that same mistake again.
And into this bowl,
we're gonna make the rest of our mixture.
So I'm gonna add some feta, some ricotta,
a little bit of mint,
a little bit of dill, some parsley
and our egg.
And we're gonna bring
this mixture together.
And the feta will definitely
bring some saltiness.
The ricotta is just gonna bring
a really delicious creaminess
and the rest of the herbs
are just gonna be very bright
and delicious in here.
So now we're going to
add our cheese mixture
to our spinach mixture.
So this is our filling
and now we're gonna get our filo
and we're gonna build these hand pies.
This is sheets of filo dough.
We'll go in with our favorite ingredient
little bit of olive oil.
Great and then we'll
put on our next layer.
So blanket right on top.
And we're just gonna keep doing this
until we have about four layers,
nice and flaky pastry.
We are going to cut this
into four even pieces.
Four even rectangles.
All right, so then we're just going
to add a pretty decent
amount of our filling.
So now I'm gonna start at the top
and I'm gonna start folding
this down into a triangle shape
And then come down, up there.
Put it down on the sheet tray.
All right, now I'm gonna pop these
into the oven for about 20, 25 minutes.
So they get nice and golden and crispy
and then they'll be ready for Tenn.
(dramatic music)
- So I met Tenn and Swasti so
like I think like four or five years ago.
Tenn was rapping
for I don't wanna say
the name of the rapper
but it was a really big rapper.
And we were at his house.
We were attending a party.
He was rapping for him.
I liked his actually his rhymes.
So I walked up to him, had a conversation.
That's when I met the both of them.
And we've been friends ever since.
Today I'm gonna be making
a Chicken Tikka Roll.
So the ingredients
that we were kind of
going off of were garlic,
olive oil and cheese.
So to incorporate those ingredients
we have chicken Tikka the
marinade will incorporate garlic,
little bit of lemon juice
and a little bit of olive oil
just to kind of bind everything together
on the Garlic Parmesan Fries.
We have the garlic,
we have a little bit of garnish on
with some parsley
and then we're gonna finally
grate some Parmesan cheese
on top of it as well.
So just to be clear,
they're really good cooks
but I know a 100%,
and I know they know
that I am the better cook out
of our entire friend circle,
no matter what.
All right, let's get started.
We're gonna make the marinade
for the Chicken Tikka Roll.
So you're gonna start with plain yogurt.
So next we're gonna do the
ginger, garlic paste in there.
Olive oil, Garam masala,
salt to taste,
coriander powder, cumin powder,
Kashmiri red chili powder, turmeric
and a splash of lemon juice.
And now you are going to combine.
So you wanna make it
as smooth as possible.
You want all that flavor
to be incorporated
into the chicken
and then we'll bring in our chicken
and we're just gonna
marinate everything together.
So at this stage,
what we're gonna do is
we're gonna cover it,
put it in the fridge for
about two hours to marinate
and then we'll bring it back out
and we'll grill 'em up.
So now the chicken has been
marinating for two hours.
So we're gonna go ahead
and get our cast iron hot.
We're gonna olive oil it up.
Always lay away from you
Since we cut these really thin,
we're gonna let 'em cook
for about five to 10 minutes.
Don't constantly flip.
Let one side cook
and then flip it just one time.
And so we're gonna put these in the oven
for about another five more minutes
and we're gonna finish them off in there.
Now we're gonna move on to step two.
We're gonna make the
Garlic Parmesan Fries.
We're gonna just chop 'em up.
You can do it however
you feel comfortable,
whatever size, whatever length.
It really goes up to you
just make sure everything
is kind of uniform.
So it cooks correctly.
Perfect, so before we fry these,
we're gonna wash 'em in water,
get rid of the starch
and then we're gonna fry up.
So we're gonna fry up our French fries
Bubble, now that they're
getting some color on them
we're going to take them off
and let them cool.
All right, now that they came
out right when they're hot
you gonna want to hit it with some salt.
And now we'll work
on our base for the Garlic Parmesan Fries.
So you'll start with some
minced garlic, parsley.
We'll do the salt taste,
white truffle oil.
(bowl mixing noise)
Perfect and then we're
just going to toss them in
and then just make sure
everything is tossed.
Make sure you coat every French fry.
So we're gonna start to build everything.
We're gonna layer some cabbage slaw.
I know he likes himself
some extra chicken.
Mint chutney on top.
We're gonna add our Garlic Parmesan Fries.
We're gonna a great sum fresh Parmesan
right on to the fries.
Here we go.
- Wow this looks good.
Wow, okay, so this is excellent.
I've got no critiques of this dish.
I have a suspicion as
to who this could be based
on the style of dish it is.
This is Indian cuisine.
And I feel like I know
who's default would be.
This is five star for me.
This is better than much better
than the ones that you microwave
cause this is very fresh considered
without the totality of the circumstances.
Meaning haven't seen the all three dishes.
I don't have any educated
guesses as to who this might be.
I also ranked this five stars
and that's not me being diplomatic.
Viewers at home if you were here
you would know
that all the food is delicious.
How's the what?
- [Director] The seasoning level.
- Oh, how's the seasoning level?
Fire, for both dishes.
I would say on point.
It looks so nice
that I almost don't even wanna,
you know, ruin how it looks.
This is incredible.
The sauce on the pasta is on point.
Me personally, I don't like
my meat to be too chewy.
So this chicken is
definitely done properly.
This is definitely five
star level quality.
I know I've given everything five stars
and that's cause everything's been great,
but this is incredible.
Now that I've had all three
I'm gonna go ahead and say
that this is my favorite dish.
This is when this is over.
This is the one
that I'm going to want
to devour immediately.
(dramatic music)
I'm locking it in.
Swasti, Sree, Codii.
Yes.
- You got it.
(clapping)
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- Yes, guess who is not
cleaning the bedroom closet.
- All right, I forgot about that.
- This guy, you forgot about the steaks?
- I forgot about the steaks.
- Boom.
- Hi, I'm Codii.
- Yes, Yes.
- Nice to meet you.
Awesome Spanokopiata.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for making
it for me.
- My pleasure.
- Yes I really appreciate it.
You did a solid job here.
And does that means
that I was correct about Sree's too?
- You always get it.
- My boy.
(laughing)
Nailed it, man.
Nailed it.
- When you were talking
about the presentation,
I was like this looks like trash.
Even back there,
when you were talking about it
I was like what presentation?
This was like
(indistinct chatters)
- Well, okay.
If you want to hear it,
that's the story of our entire life.
Like she'll come out every day
and be like look in the mirror
and be like, oh I look like
(beeping sound)
And I'll be like, you seen
You look boom every day.